anoche estas calles del centro de
santiago el diana registrar incidentes
violante es un grupo no muy grande de
personas salían a la calle a manifestar
su rabia tras los contundentes
resultados del plebiscito electoral en
chile en el que rechazó se impuso por un
gran margen de ventaja todavía se
respira los gases lacrimógenos en este
lugar sin embargo la tónica fue en
general las celebraciones por el triunfo
del rechazo en diversos puntos del país
con banderas con bailes de cueca y otros
de sistemas relacionados con la
tradicionalidad chilena el tema es qué
es lo que va a ocurrir a partir de ahora
las miradas están puestas en la reunión
que mantendrá el presidente boris en la
moneda con los representantes de los
distintos partidos políticos para
iniciar un itinerario constituyente que
pueda llevar hacia adelante un nuevo
proceso que manifieste los cambios
demandados por la ciudadanía mientras
que muchos de los partidos de la derecha
de chile vamos de lo que fue el de lo
que es la oposición y fue el anterior
gobierno han manifestado su deseo de
continuar en este trayecto
constitucional
a chile de una nueva constitución lo
cierto es que también se han restado de
esta reunión que tendrá lugar en la
moneda en el día de hoy